As our calendars approach 2020, the reigning
king of the streaming wars, Netflix, is getting
rid of a number of movies to make room for
everything that's coming to the site at the
start of the new year.
These are the movies you have to watch before
they leave Netflix in January 2020.
Even in a brand-new decade, Grease is still
the word - but it won't retain that status
on Netflix after January 31, 2020.
The 1978 film, a silver-screen adaptation
of the 1971 musical of the same name, features
Olivia Newton-John and John Travolta as a
pair of clique-crossed high school sweethearts
who navigate their whirlwind romance, the
status quo at Rydell High, and greaser culture
with plenty of song and dance.
If you've somehow yet to see Grease and are
unfamiliar with the rockin'-and-rollin' Danny
Zuko and his sweet-turned-sassy Australian
squeeze Sandy Olsson, now's the perfect time
to catch the film from the comfort of your
couch.
And if you're like the vast majority of people
in the world and simply can't resist the charms
of the film's characters and infectiously
cheery soundtrack, don't miss out on streaming
Grease for the thousandth time on Netflix
before the month is up.
Taking a hard left turn away from the feel-good
fun of Grease, we arrive at American Psycho
- director Mary Harron's half-black-comedy,
half-psychological-horror that adapts Bret
Easton Ellis' novel of the same name into
a story that simmers below the surface before
it splatters all over the place.
Released in April 2000 to much critical acclaim,
American Psycho centers around the well-to-do,
detail-oriented investment banker Patrick
Bateman, whose obsessions, insecurities, and
penchant for extreme violence build to bursting.
"I guess…
I'm a pretty…
I mean, I guess I'm a pretty sick guy."
This one's not for the faint of heart or anyone
with a fear of chainsaws, but for those wanting
a terrifying flick to get sucked into, you
have until January 31, 2020 to watch American
Psycho on Netflix.
Before she was a teen girl who fell in love
with a vampire, prior to her string of acclaimed
indie flicks, and years ahead of her stint
as one of Charlie's Angels, Kristen Stewart
splashed onto the Hollywood scene with her
breakout film role in 2002's Panic Room.
In director David Fincher's thriller, Stewart
stars as Sarah Altman, the daughter of Jodie
Foster's character Meg Altman.
The mother-daughter pair move into a new home
- a multi-story brownstone nestled in New
York City's Upper West Side neighborhood - following
Meg's recent divorce.
You may predict where the plot is headed - that
Meg and Sarah's new home is haunted by entities
hungry for revenge - but Panic Room plays
out differently.
Meg and Sarah discover that the previous owner
of the home built a "panic room," a fortified
hiding place to protect occupants in the event
of a home invasion, natural disaster, or other
threat of the same ilk.
But that's not all that's inside the home.
Trouble comes knocking on the Altmans' door
the very first night they move in: the grandson
of the previous owner, Junior - along with
his two accomplices Burnham and Raoul - break
into the home in search of $3 million locked
in a floor safe inside the panic room.
The Altmans engage in a life-or-death game
of cat-and-mouse with the trio of home invaders,
who are determined to seize the money by whatever
means necessary.
Panic Room is available to stream on Netflix
until January 31, 2020.
2019 saw the theatrical launch of Zombieland:
Double Tap, the long-awaited sequel to 2009's
beloved zombie comedy Zombieland.
The flick, directed by returning helmer Ruben
Fleischer, catapulted the property back into
pop culture consciousness, and had people
scrambling to rewatch the original Zombieland.
"Heh heh heh heh heh heh!"
Whether you saw the sequel in cinemas or decided
to skip it, the OG flick holds up better than
Twinkies do in a zombie apocalypse - so in
January 2020, sit down with "mad person disease"
survivors Tallahassee, Columbus, Wichita,
and Little Rock and watch as they fight off
hordes of zombies, share their rules for avoiding
death, and form their dysfunctional-yet-lovable
makeshift family.
Zombieland leaves Netflix on January 31, 2020.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.